let's get some more background on the
situation welcome shredder joins us now
he's an economist with the East European
Institute at Berlin's fire University or
free university tell us this has been a
tug of war from the very beginning
between Russia and the EU with varying
degrees of tugging how would you
describe the situation well it all
depends how we got into this and it
could be that this was long planned by
mr. Putin as some suspect it could be
that both sides stumbled into it due to
the Ukrainian developments I don't know
what the real cause is suppose mr. Putin
stumbled into this then he should be
interested in a peaceful solution for
this how that could look like I don't
know but maybe a far-reaching autonomy
for eastern Ukraine could be the
solution but if he didn't stumble into
this well then i stiii don't see a
peaceful outcome actually there will be
fighting going on in East and eastern
Ukraine in Kiev we have the
demonstrations already or that doesn't
look too good then what's better for
Ukraine Russia or the EU well it's it's
it's it's a bridge between Eastern
Europe between Russia and the European
Union and actually what mr. Putin is
afraid of is that the European Union and
the West maybe even NATO moves closer to
Russian borders my point of view would
be that that's the best that can happen
to him because if you bordering closely
to the European Union that's a recipe to
develop and get rich so he would some of
that wealth would rub off on him and he
is irrationally opposed to this out of
no good reason but in actual fact when
you look at Ukraine I suppose the best
for the Ukrainians is a combination of
the two it's a combination which of
course means membership neither in the
Eurasian Union that mr. Putin is
planning nor full membership in the
European Union some sort of getting
closer approaching it but not being
member let's take a look at the numbers
because if we look at Ukraine's export
partners on a country-by-country basis
Russia plays the most important role by
far there's no doubt about that
Turkey's way behind in second place then
there's China and further down the list
is Germany so economically there's no
way that Ukraine's interim government
can just cut off the country from Russia
politics and economics go hand-in-hand
how is this going to play out do you
think
well the non Russian customers of the
Ukraine will not stop importing from
from Ukraine the danger is Russia if
Russia decides that we are not going to
buy anymore let's say on ton of
airplanes then there is no way how to
solve this problem Lufthansa will not
begin to buy an ton of airliners because
Ukraine is important on an industrial
yes so so everything depends on the
goodwill of Russia and how well well
develop that goodwill is no one knows
mhm what about the Ukrainian economy
what sort of shape is it in it's in a
terrible shape and that hasn't developed
yesterday that has developed over many
many years misguided policies living
beyond the means of the country much
like Greece and there is however a
solution for the Ukraine which the
Greeks don't have at their disposal and
that's to develop tear to devalue the
currency Greece is stuck in the euro
cannot develop Ukraine can and actually
has willy-nilly already devalued that is
sort of the first step important and key
step towards a solution there are many
more steps that it need to be done but
Ukraine at least the previous government
has been absolutely reluctant to
implement anything the IMF has been
telling them and just briefly there is
economic potential there there is I mean
as interest coming from all sides at all
yeah the Ukraine is interesting both as
far as industrial production is
concerned and agricultural production
most well-known is of course the
agricultural production so everyone will
be willing to buy grain from Ukraine no
one will decide as sabotage my my own
demand no mr. Shekar oh thank you very
much for the analysis very interesting
welcome